.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wow!
Das sieht super aus.
Könnte so
schon bald die Zukunft aussehen?
Renato Jordan will
auf seiner ehemaligen Schafweide
oberhalb von Gondo im Oberwallis,
auf 2'000 m ü.M.,
Strom im grossen Stil produzieren.
Zum ersten Mal
soll im hochalpinen Gelände
ein Solarpark
in der freien Natur entstehen.
Ein Pionierprojekt,
das Widerstand weckt.
Wir sind nun hier auf der Alpjerung.
Hier entsteht die Solaranlage.
Dort drüben
ist die italienische Grenze.
Dort sind wir bereits in Italien.
Die Anlage entsteht hier.
Hier nach oben und die ganze Gegend
bis ganz nach unten.
Das sind ungefähr 100'000 m2,
die dann mit Panels besetzt sind.
In diesem Film möchte ich
herausfinden, warum dieser Mann -
pensionierter Gymnasiallehrer
und Geograf -
nun noch Solarpionier werden will.
Hallo?
- Hier ist Renato Jordan.
Wir möchten mit einem Kamerateam
zwei, drei Aufnahmen machen.
Können wir schnell reinkommen?
Geht es nach Jordan,
soll dieses Kraftwerk
in seinem Projekt
eine wichtige Rolle spielen.
Wir machen etwas für Gondosolar.
Hier will er die Sonnenenergie
von Gondosolar einspeisen.
Gondosolar -
so nennt er die geplante Anlage.
Das ist der Rudutschuggu.
Da. Und dort oben
hat es zwei, drei Stufen
und dahinter ist der Alpjerung.
Dort installieren wir Gondosolar,
die Photovoltaikanlage.
Der Alpjerung -
ein kleiner Flecken für grosse Pläne.
14 Fussballfelder gross
soll nämlich die gesamte Anlage
werden.
Die Visualisierung zeigt
die ganze Grösse des Solarparks.
Für sein Sonnenprojekt
ist Renato Jordan selbst
oft nach Sonnenuntergang unterwegs.
An diesem Abend
tritt er an einem Anlass auf,
organisiert durch die Mitte-Frauen.
Lobbyarbeit,
denn er braucht möglichst bald
die Baubewilligung des Kanton Wallis.
Fossil ist keine Lösung.
Als Geograf war es schon immer
mein Ziel, zu sagen:
Wir können doch nicht
Material oder Grundstoffe,
die 60 Mio. Jahre brauchten,
um zu entstehen,
innerhalb von drei bis vier
Generationen verbrennen,
um unseren Arsch zu heizen.
Der Alpjerung ist die Gegend, in der
wir Gondosolar machen möchten.
Es ist ein Hochplateau
auf 2'000 m ü.M. und höher.
D.h.,
dort ist die Atmosphäre sehr dünn
und die Sonne
kann ungehindert durchgehen.
Das ist ein riesiger Vorteil.
Wenn wir die offizielle Nebelkarte
der Schweiz anschauen:
Das ist die offizielle Karte -
von 2007 allerdings.
Wir können diese
mit der Bevölkerungsdichte
des Bundesamts für Statistik 2023
vergleichen:
Da sieht man,
dass die meisten Leute hier leben.
Und dort
hat es auch am meisten Gebäude.
Und wo die meisten Gebäude sind,
hat es
die meisten Dächer und Fassaden.
Das ist doch logisch, oder?
So sieht das aus.
Überall Nebel - ausser im Wallis.
Das ist keine Zauberei.
Das ist ein Bild von "Meteo Schweiz"
vom 26. Januar 2023.
Im Publikum befinden sich
Gemeinderätinnen, Grossrätinnen
und auch Mitte-Ständerat Beat Rieder
aus dem Wallis ist anwesend.
Rieder hat ein nationales Solargesetz
in Bern durchgeboxt.
Wer bis 2025 Strom produziert,
erhält bis zu 60 % der Kosten
vom Bund zurückerstattet.
Jordans Projekt ist unter Zeitdruck.
Ich habe geschlossen.
Merci.
Gratuliere.
Das war ein sehr gutes Referat.
Merci.
- Das ziehen wir durch.
Ich denke,
dass ich das Publikum erreicht habe.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Und sie haben begriffen,
worum es mir geht.
Steht die Anlage jetzt?
Verdammt noch mal.
Wir sind dran.
Wir arbeiten. Wir labern nicht nur.
Wir mussten aber zuerst
das Gesetz im Schnellgang machen.
Merci. Super.
Seit 1848 das erste Gesetz
in drei Wochen.
Das weisst du, oder?
- Nein.
Jetzt weisst du es.
- Dafür haben wir dich.
Es war schwierig.
- Dafür haben wir solche Leute.
Dringliches Bundesgesetz,
seit 1848 das erste und einzige
in einer Session.
Grengiols
wird nächste Woche vorgestellt.
Gut.
- Es sieht hervorragend aus.
Tipptopp.
- Ist noch eine Woche Session?
Ja, noch eine Woche. Voilà.
Wir müssen alles geben.
- Gas geben.
Gas.
- Nein, Solar geben.
Sonne geben.
- Sonne geben.
Renato Jordans Projekt
hat die Diskussion
um alpine Solaranlagen
in der Schweiz angestossen.
Mir scheint, seine Mission,
die Leute zu überzeugen,
sei an diesem Abend gelungen.
Im Vergleich zu anderen Anlagen
ist es eine relativ kleine Anlage.
Es wäre vielleicht auch die erste.
So kann sie als Pilotprojekt gelten.
Darüber kann man reden.
Aber wenn wir über 5-km2-Anlagen
in unberührter Landschaft reden -
das geht für mich nicht.
Ganz ehrlich: Ich bin begeistert.
Er hat das sehr gut vorgetragen
und logische Argumente gebracht.
Um es auf den Punkt zu bringen:
Es gibt nichts gratis.
Wir brauchen Strom.
Wir alle brauchen Strom.
Irgendwo muss der Strom herkommen.
Aus der Luft kommt er nicht.
Er war schon sehr überzeugend.
Dass sein Projekt längst nicht alle
begeistert, davon später mehr.
Im Bergdorf Gondo im Kanton Wallis,
beim Simplonpass,
wächst Renato Jordan auf.
Einen Steinwurf zur Grenze Italiens.
Für Renato Jordan
eine prägende Kindheit,
eng verbunden
mit dem Dorf und der Natur.
In seinen Träumen,
so sagt mir der 72-Jährige,
kehre er fast jede Nacht
an seinen Heimatort zurück.
Wer von hier kommt,
hat schon früh erfahren,
welche Naturgewalten
auf die Erde wirken.
Das da ist ein sehr spezieller Ort.
Bei diesem P.
Genau hier stand mein Elternhaus.
Das wurde bei der Katastrophe
vor über 20 Jahren
mitsamt dem Fundament weggerissen,
hinunter in die Tiefe.
Wir haben nichts mehr gesehen.
Ein Erdrutsch zerstört einen Drittel
des Walliser Grenzdörfchens
und reisst 13 Menschen in den Tod.
Dieser schwarze Tag hat in Gondo
bis heute tiefe Spuren hinterlassen.
Renato Jordan
und seine vier Geschwister
lebten zu diesem Zeitpunkt
nicht mehr in Gondo.
Auch sein Vater hielt sich
in einem anderen Teil des Dorfes auf
und überlebte das Unglück.
Wir hatten
viele wichtige Sachen da drin.
Es wurde nichts gefunden.
Es war alles weg.
Genau hier. Hier war der Keller.
Hoi.
- Salut.
Natürlich weiss ich noch genau,
wie jedes Zimmer ausgesehen hat.
Aber emotional ist hier nichts mehr.
Ja.
Sein Leben hat viele Facetten:
Geograf, pensionierter
Gymnasiallehrer, Familienvater,
Künstler und nun auch Solarpionier.
Die Energieproduktion
war schon immer wichtig
für die Gemeinde Gondo-Zwischbergen.
Bereits seit über 70 Jahren
produziert man hier
Strom aus erneuerbaren Energien.
Schau das mal an,
das ist der blaue Putz.
Dort hinten schauten wir immer
von der Höhle hinunter
in die Tiefe des Sees.
Das war verrückt.
Jährlich produzieren in der Region
drei Wasserkraftwerke
Strom für rund 57'000 Haushalte.
Im Durchschnitt
nimmt die kleine Berggemeinde
damit 1 Mio. Fr.
durch Wasserzinsen ein.
Es ist eine raue Gegend,
ein enges Tal.
Trotzdem hat man hier
Visionen für die ganze Schweiz.
Renato Jordan will - wie
die Generationen vor ihm auch schon -
in das Geschäft
der Energieproduktion einsteigen.
Es gibt ja Leute, die sagen,
dir gehe es nur ums Geldverdienen.
Was sagst du dazu?
- Es geht mir nicht nur darum.
Ich hatte anfangs eine Idee
und dachte nicht an das hier.
Für mich ist es sehr wichtig,
dass wir von den Fossilen wegkommen.
Das ist für mich
etwas vom Wichtigsten.
Es kann ja nicht sein,
dass wir Erdöl, das in
über 60 Mio. Jahren entstanden ist,
innerhalb von drei bis vier
Generationen verbrennen,
um uns den Arsch zu heizen.
Die Generationen, die kommen,
haben nur noch eine dreckige Umwelt
und keine Rohstoffe mehr.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Das ist einer meiner Hauptantriebe.
Aber natürlich muss ich sagen:
Das Geld ist auch ein Antrieb, klar.
Inzwischen wohnt Renato Jordan
mit seiner Familie
in der Talebene in Brig.
Hier hat der pensionierte Gymnasial-
lehrer und Künstler sein Atelier,
beschäftigt sich im Moment
v.a. mit digitaler Kunst.
* Spassige Glockenmusik *
Was ist der Zusammenhang
zwischen Kunst und Energie?
Gibt es einen?
Ich glaube, in der Kunst
braucht es eine gewisse Kreativität,
damit man das überhaupt machen kann.
Ich bin auch überzeugt davon,
dass es in der Energiesituation,
in welcher wir uns in der Schweiz
oder weltweit befinden,
auch Fantasie braucht.
Und dass sich kreative Leute
dem Problem annehmen müssen,
die das in die Finger nehmen und
Initiative dafür ergreifen können.
Sonst gibt es ja nichts,
wenn nichts Neues entsteht.
Wir können nicht
immer nur auf dem verharren,
was unsere Vorfahren gemacht haben.
Wir können nicht da bleiben und dann
sagen, es gebe keine Entwicklung.
Es braucht eine Entwicklung.
* Verspielte Musik *
Das Sonnenlicht
ist an diesem Morgen noch weit weg:
Ich begleite Renato Jordan und seine
Leute an einem für sie wichtigen Tag.
Seit Monaten
haben sie dafür gearbeitet,
jetzt steht oben auf dem Berg
eine Testanlage.
Er sieht sie heute zum ersten Mal.
Es war schwer, einzuschlafen.
- Salü. Ich bin Renato.
Ist sie weiss? So halbweiss.
- Ja, vom Salz.
Ja.
Es hat ganz leicht angeschneit,
aber schon sehr wenig.
Letztes Mal ging ich
mit den Österreichern rauf.- Ja.
Die hatten eine riesige Freude.
Jetzt fahren wir
von Brig nach Simplon-Dorf.
Dort erwartet uns der Helikopter,
der uns auf den Alpjerung bringt.
Dorthin,
wo wir Gondosolar aufstellen werden.
Jordan und die beiden Ingenieure
überprüfen die hochalpine Testanlage.
Es muss alles stimmen,
damit diese Wind, Wetter
und v.a. den Winter übersteht.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Jetzt gehen wir da hinauf.
Auf den Rücken, den du siehst.
Das Band, das da leuchtet,
ist unsere Testanlage.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Die Aussicht hier
ist einfach phänomenal.
Wunderbar.
Die Standortvorteile auf dieser Höhe:
Wenig Nebel,
und im Winter reflektiert der Schnee
zusätzlich auf die Panels.
Gerade in der kalten Jahreszeit
produziert eine solche Anlage
bis zu viermal mehr Strom
als im Mittelland.
Was man hier sieht,
ist die Testanlage.
Hier geht es darum zu sehen,
wie sich Wind und Wetter verhalten.
Wir nehmen an, dass das der Ort
mit den stärksten Winden ist.
Wenn diese Testanlage das aushält,
sind wir sicher,
dass sie
denen dort unten auch standhält.
Dort hat es weniger Wind.
Dort ist es weniger gefährlich.
Früher brachte die Familie Jordan
ihre Schafe auf diese Alp.
Zukünftig sollen hier Solarelemente
Strom für rund 4'500 Haushalte
liefern.
Es ist ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt
von Initiant Renato Jordan,
der Gemeinde Gondo-Zwischbergen
und eines lokalen Stromerzeugers,
dessen Hauptaktionär
der Stromkonzern Alpiq ist.
Ist das so machbar mit dem Boden?
Sieht das gut aus?
Oder wird das sehr schwierig sein?
Das geht schon.
- Das geht? Ja.
Die eingesetzten Solarzellen
sind bifazial.
D.h., die Panels können
beidseitig Sonnenenergie aufnehmen.
Dies sei auf Hausdächern und Fassaden
kaum möglich.
Die Kosten fürs Gesamtprojekt:
rund 50 Mio. Fr.
Unterstützungsgelder des Bundes
sind zwingend nötig -
sonst
rechnet sich der Solarpark nicht.
Diese Gesamtübersicht brauche ich.
- Also müsste man so reinfliegen.
Genau und von oben rein.
Wo?
- Hier auf der Kuppe, denke ich.
Ja, ja.
Aber wir dürfen wahrscheinlich
nicht zu weit rübergehen.
Eben, das ...
Wenn da eine Lawine abgeht, kann
die sogar hier wieder raufkommen.
Ja.
Aber die kommt so alle 300 Jahre.
Wobei ...
Die 300 Jahre sind so eine Sache,
oder?
Ja. Es kann sein,
dass sie nächstes Jahr kommt.
Hier wäre nicht so schlimm.
* Lachen *
Hier wäre gut.
Dann würde man sehen, was passiert.
Wir könnten die künstlich auslösen,
aber dort drüben ist Italien.- Ja.
Wir dürfen nicht rüber.
- Die Grenze geht da durch.
Sonst müssten wir zuerst nach Rom.
Ja.
Was ist die Schwierigkeit
mit den Lawinen?
Zu wissen, wie weit
oder wie nahe die Lawine kommt.
Und wie nahe der Lawinendruck kommt.
Und welche Lawinen kommen:
Fliesslawinen oder Staublawinen?
Das ist noch in Abklärung.
Hier müsst ihr aufpassen,
um kein Bein zu verdrehen.
Nicht zu schnell gehen.
- Nein, nein.
Jetzt ist es sehr warm.
- Eine verdammte Hitze.
Aber wir können froh sein,
dass es keinen Wind hat.- Ja, ja.
Solch eine Anlage zu bauen
ist Pionierarbeit.
Die Erschliessung
der Hochgebirgsbaustelle
mit zwei temporären Seilbahnen,
die Topografie
und die extremen Bedingungen
fordern die Ingenieure.
Die grosse Challenge
ist herauszufinden,
wie sich die Anlage zukünftig
auf den Wind und
die Schneeverfrachtungen auswirkt.
Wenn die Anlage gebaut ist,
verändert das
die Oberflächenstruktur
und kann Auswirkungen
auf die Schneeablagerungen haben.
Im dümmsten Fall
haben wir Schnee in der Anlage,
den wir jetzt nicht haben.
Du kannst das verändern, oder?
Du veränderst das.
Ja, ja.
- Das ist klar.
Wenn du ein Gartenhaus aufstellst,
gibt es dahinter Schneeanhäufungen.
Bereits seit drei Jahren
ist ein kleines Team
rund um Jordan an der Planung.
Alpiq hat bisher
mehrere Hunderttausend Franken
ins Projekt gesteckt.
Doch wer unberührte Natur
bebauen will,
muss mit Widerstand aus dem Natur-
und Landschaftsschutz rechnen.
Wir arbeiten sorgfältig
und sind schon lange an der Planung.
Wir haben Flora, Fauna, Geologie und
Naturgefahren sehr gut untersucht.
Und weil wir sie
miteinbeziehen wollen,
könnten wir bei den Umweltverbänden
einen guten Stand haben.
Rückhalt erhält Renato Jordan von
seiner Gemeinde Gondo-Zwischbergen.
Hier hat es Tradition,
mit Strom Geld zu verdienen.
Das Dorf steht finanziell so gut da,
dass es einen Teil der Krankenkasse
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger bezahlt.
An der Urversammlung sind
die Meinungen zu Gondosolar gemacht.
Wir kommen zu Punkt 1:
Die allgemeine Frage,
ob die Gemeinde
das Projekt unterstützen soll.
Wer ist dafür, dass so zu machen?
Gibt es Gegenstimmen?
Enthaltungen?
Einstimmig angenommen. Danke.
Punkt 2: Soll die Gemeinde
als Projektträger
eine aktive Rolle einnehmen?
Wer ist dafür?
Ist jemand dagegen?
Gibt es Enthaltungen?
Das scheint einstimmig zu sein,
merci vielmals.
Jetzt gibt es zuerst
einen gemütlichen Apéro
und danach wird sich das so ergeben.
Ist das gut?
Merci. Einen schönen Sonntag.
* Applaus *
Volle Unterstützung fürs Projekt
von der Heimatgemeinde.
Doch kräftigen Widerstand
gibt's von anderer Seite:
Umweltschützerin Vera Weber
und ihre Stiftung
stellen sich in der Öffentlichkeit
gegen alpine Solarprojekte.
Sie ist Präsidentin
der Fondation Franz Weber
und will sich persönlich
ein Bild vor Ort machen.
Auf Einladung von "Reporter"
wandert sie zur abgelegenen Weide.
Was erwarten Sie, wenn wir da oben
Gondosolar erreichen?
Ich denke, das wird eine einmalige,
intakte Landschaft sein -
wie ich das auf Fotos gesehen habe
und aus Berichten kenne.
Solche Landschaften
muss man intakt behalten.
Da darf nichts gebaut werden.
Unsere Landschaften in der Schweiz
sind schon jetzt sehr begrenzt.
Der Alpjerung
liegt weit weg von der Zivilisation:
eine Bergtour
von zweieinhalb Stunden.
Da muss man schwindelfrei sein.
Bereits Vera Webers Vater,
Franz Weber,
hat sich als Initiant
der Zeitwohnungsinitiative
für den Landschaftsschutz eingesetzt.
Wir müssen die Menschen
sensibilisieren und informieren,
andere Wege aufzeigen und betonen,
dass es andere Wege geben muss.
Sie können mir nicht sagen,
dass das schön ist,
auch wenn das Holz ist.
Es gab in der Raumplanung,
im Naturschutzgesetz,
in den letzten Jahrzehnten
so viele Errungenschaften.
Und jetzt will man
alles über Bord werfen
und auf dem Altar der Energiekrise
und des Klimaschutzes opfern.
Man darf den Umwelt-
und den Naturschutz
nicht gegen den Klimaschutz
ausspielen.
Das dürfen wir nicht akzeptieren.
Nicht gegeneinander ausspielen -
aber was ist denn die Lösung
für den Winterstrom,
den wir nur hier oben und nicht
auf den Dächern produzieren können?
Es gibt
in sehr vielen höhergelegenen Orten
bereits Infrastrukturen.
In Berggebieten,
auch bei Bergstationen.
Da könnte man wirklich auch
mit Solarpanels arbeiten.
Diese stark bebauten Gebiete
mit Solarpanels bestücken,
und auch die Dächer
in diesen hohen Lagen,
anstatt freie, intakte Natur
zuzupflastern.
Die Gegenseite ist überzeugt,
dass es auch Gondosolar brauche,
um genügend Strom zu produzieren.
Zudem habe ein Solarforscher
den Standort als sehr geeignet
für die Stromproduktion eingeschätzt.
* Verspielte Musik *
Renato Jordan und Vera Weber haben
sich noch nie persönlich getroffen.
Bei diesem Dreh von "SRF Reporter"
sehen sich die beiden zum ersten Mal.
Voilà. Jawohl.
Grüezi. Freut mich.
- Frau Weber. Renato Jordan.
Freut mich sehr, Herr Jordan.
Sie waren auf dem Alpjerung.
- Ja.
Auf diesem wunderbaren Fleck
Schweizer Landschaft.
Schön, oder?
- Ein Traum, wirklich.
Schön.
- Ja.
Also können wir uns unterhalten.
Am besten ist so.
Sie können hier sitzen.
So sehen wir beide
auf den Bildschirm.
Ich kann Ihnen
mehrere Sachen zeigen.
Herr Professor Rohrer
hat geschrieben:
"Alpjerung befindet sich
an einer sehr guten Lage."
"Eine alpine Photovoltaikanlage
in dem Gebiet
könnte
ein nationales Vorzeigeprojekt
mit Ausstrahlung weit über
die Landesgrenzen hinaus werden."
Und die Betonsockel?
- Also, die Betonsockel ...
Photovoltaikpanels
sind ja nicht recycelbar.
Doch. Das ist alles recycelbar.
Wir haben uns da informiert.
Wir treffen uns regelmässig
mit diesen vier Umweltverbänden:
Stiftung Landschaftsschutz Schweiz -
Herr Rodewald ist auch dabei -
der WWF, Pro Natura und neustens
auch Mountain Wilderness.
Wir sind nicht Teil dieser Gruppen,
die sie da gezeigt haben.
Ja, ja, ich weiss.
- Aber wir sind immer offen.
Gut.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit und diese
kurze, eindrückliche Präsentation.
Merci.
Ich wünsche Ihnen alles Gute.
- Alles Gute, Frau Weber.
Vielleicht hören wir
wieder voneinander. Das wäre gut.
Danke.
Ich konnte sie nicht erreichen.
Das hat gar nichts gebracht.
Ob Vera Weber gegen das Projekt
Einsprache erheben wird,
ist noch offen.
Auf meine Nachfrage
mochte sie keine klare Antwort geben.
Sicher ist jedoch,
dass ihre Stiftung das Referendum
gegen das nationale
Stromversorgungsgesetz unterstützt.
Kommt es zustande
und wird vom Volk angenommen,
könnte es für alle zukünftigen alpi-
nen Solarprojekte schwierig werden.
Nimmst du ein Bier?
- Nein, nein.
Was denn? Eine Coca-Cola Zero?
- Ja, eine Coca-Cola Zero.
Jeder sitzt da, wo er möchte.
- Ah, ich bin ...
Nimmst du den weissen Thron?
- Ja, den weissen Thron.
Hast du irgendwo die Traktanden,
an denen ich mich orientieren kann?
Herzlich willkommen.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr alle da seid.
Einladung und Traktandenliste
habt ihr gekriegt, einverstanden?
Für Gondosolar wird das Kunstatelier
zum Sitzungsraum.
Regelmässig treffen sich hier
die Projektverantwortlichen.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Renato Jordan, Vertreter der Gemeinde
und der Energieunternehmung.
Der Druck auf die Verantwortlichen
steigt.
Ein überparteiliches Komitee
will schnellere Baubewilligungsver-
fahren für Solarprojekte verhindern.
Es wird zur Abstimmung kommen.
Dann kämen wir zum Terminplan.
Hat sich da was geändert?
Es zeichnet sich ab:
Bis 2025 Strom zu produzieren,
wird knapp.
Das ist das Ziel
und das ist erreichbar.
Aber klar:
Es braucht gewisse Bedingungen.
Eine ist, dass die Baubewilligung
irgendwann kommt.
Und auch das Material.
Also,
es ist nicht alles so eindeutig.
Es kann Verzögerungen
wegen Einsprachen geben.
Und danach
auch mit den Lieferketten.
Da gab es in den letzten Jahren
immer wieder Risiken.
Aber das Ziel haben wir und möchten
gerne zeigen, dass es nicht so ist.
Die Eingabe der Baubewilligung
wird sich verzögern.
Nach einer Auswertung
ordnen die Ingenieure
die Solarmodule neu an.
Solarbäume soll es nun geben -
dem Wald rundherum nachempfunden.
Sie seien gleich effizient,
gliederten sich aber
besser in die Landschaft ein.
* "Tagesinfo"-Signet *
Zehntausende Solarzellen
in unseren Alpen.
Für manche ein Albtraum
und eine Verschandelung der Natur.
Für andere ein nötiger Beitrag
für die Energieversorgung.
Am 10. September
stimmt das Walliser Volk darüber ab,
ob Baubewilligungsverfahren
für Photovoltaikgrossanlagen
verschnellert werden sollen.
Es ist der Tag der Wahrheit
für Renato Jordans Projekt:
Die kantonale Abstimmung wird für
die ganze Schweiz wegweisend sein.
Eigentlich möchte er den Tag
allein verbringen.
Doch ich darf ihn
mit der Kamera begleiten,
wenn die grosse Entscheidung fällt.
Mit welchem Gefühl
gehen Sie in den Tag?
Ich habe ein gutes Gefühl,
aber ich rechne natürlich mit allem.
Es ist eine demokratische Abstimmung
und da muss man schauen, was kommt.
Keine Ahnung.
Prognose?
Keine. Hoffnung.
Prognose keine, Hoffnung schon.
* Er pfeift vor sich hin. *
* Kirchenglocken *
Ab 12 Uhr gibt es erste Resultate.
Die Gemeinde Zwischbergen
hat abgestimmt.
Gondos Präsident
hat mir gerade geschrieben.
Zu 100 % für das Solardekret.
Ein Ja von Gondo.
Ein gutes Zeichen?
- Das ist schon mal was.
Doch die Freude währt nicht lange.
Ich kriege die Meldung, dass es
im Unterwallis ein klares Nein gibt.
Die Abstimmung
sieht nicht einfach nur gut aus.
Jetzt ist alles ausgezählt.
46 % zu 54 % Nein.
Abgelehnt.
Ein Nein zu
schnelleren Baubewilligungsverfahren.
Ja, was will man machen?
Es ist wirklich
ein schlechtes Zeichen.
Gondo und Grengiols im Wallis
waren die Ersten
und jetzt sieht man, was die Bündner
und die Berner machen -
die überholen uns noch.
Das ist etwas peinlich.
- Das ist fast peinlich, ja.
Wir haben mit dem Ganzen angefangen.
- Genau.
Jetzt ist es halt so.
Nach aussen wirkt Renato Jordan
trotz der Niederlage gefasst,
aber ich merke,
dass er enttäuscht ist.
Ja ...
Ich habe keine Freude,
ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe keine Freude.
Aber das wird mich
nicht daran hindern,
diese Idee weiterzuführen.
Ich will weitermachen.
Und wir werden gewinnen.
Wir werden gewinnen.
Das Ziel bis 2025
Strom zu produzieren, ist fraglich.
Aufgeben ist für den Solarpionier
keine Option.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023